so me and magnus are going to try a  chess quiz on kahoot  and we're challenging you viewers at  home as well  how can you do against us one two  [Music]  three  [Music]  what's the name of this mite  [Laughter]  oh jesus  it's gonna be hard to count  this is just gonna be a guess  what did you guess did you get it right  yeah  so the next match will be the 50th wow  okay so third place  [Music]  oh they actually played a third place  match and then maxim won that one oh  yeah i didn't really pay attention after  i hadn't got my cards  what's the name of the mate  what i have no idea  bongo me sounds like it  [Music]  oh  [Music]  what did you guess one nine less less  come on can't be that little  2010  [Music]  pretty sure pretty sure yeah because  i think rojava was second and that was  third  now this one  [Music]  someone's trolling me